the earth sits comfortably in its orbit
tilted on its axis at 23 degrees knock
the planet over and it wouldn't be the
earth as you know it
how can a slight change in its axial
tilt make the planet uninhabitable this
is what if and here's what would happen
if the Earth's axis was tilted by 90
degrees only two planets in the solar
system lie on their sides Uranus and the
dwarf planet Pluto now if something took
the earth off its stand the blue planet
would have no chance of developing any
complex life on its surface but let's
start at the beginning this axial tilt
or obliquity is what drives the seasons
here on earth before the collision that
created the moon the Earth's axis was
slowly wobbling around somewhere between
0 and 85 degrees then our newly formed
moons stabilized it but if that
collision happened at a different time
things would have turned out very
different here on earth it would be a
strange new world as the earth made its
way through orbit its poles would be
pointing straight towards the Sun one
hemisphere would be shrouded in darkness
for six months straight while the other
would be getting cooked by the Blazing
Sun light one day on earth would last a
whole year
at the North Pole the daytime
temperatures would rise to a broiling 50
degrees a day at the South Pole would be
even worse because the South Pole would
be located away from climate controlling
ocean currents it would heat up to an
almost boiling 80 degrees the poles
would soak up so much heat from the Sun
that they wouldn't even freeze during
the six-month long night you wouldn't
recognize the steaming equatorial
tropics with a 90 degree axial tilt part
of the equator would stay encased in ice
all year round at some point in this
Earth's existence our continents would
get clumped together around one of the
poles inland temperatures in the daytime
would get truly hellish reaching the
boiling temperature of water clouds
could help the situation and not let all
the water vapor off the planet but you
wouldn't know you wouldn't stick around
that long in this scorching heat the
best case scenario was see just a few
kinds of bacteria survive those bacteria
might evolve into more complex life
forms but they wouldn't be anywhere
close to how complex we turned out to be
the reason would be a lack of oxygen
green plants would be having a hard time
surviving during the six months of
complete darkness they drop their seeds
at nightfall to grow after sunrise but
in these conditions would they even have
evolved in the first place
interestingly enough if the earth was 60
million kilometers further away from the
Sun a 90 degree axial tilt wouldn't be
so bad the temperatures at the poles
would never raise above 46 degrees
during the day the coldest it would get
at night would be three degrees the only
place covered with ice would be the
highest mountains
so you see simply orbiting a star in the
habitable zone doesn't mean that a
planet is actually capable of sustaining
life we're the lucky ones living here on
earth maybe one day we'll discover
another exoplanet just like our home but
that's a story for another what if
[Music]
you